welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down No Country for all
men this com brother classic completely
shook me to the core and I can't wait to
go back through it and talk about the
movie Set during 1980 it's a game of
life and death and we follow a man who
finds himself into deep just something
about it sticks with you forever and
there's a lot of things going on deep
below the surface throughout this video
I want to dive into the film and discuss
I think it's a stone cold classic once
we through it I hope you'll agree with
me too as there's so many things going
on in the film now starting it up I was
instantly reminded about one of the cool
things that the movie does that is that
there's next to no music throughout the
entire
[Music]
piece well we'll accept that bit but
other than that the soundtrack Stripped
Away which gives the movie an atmosphere
and intensity to it it of course also
helps to ground it in reality as none of
us walk through life with a Man of Steel
soundtrack blasting in our ear well
unless you're Patrick baitman either way
at its core I think what makes it so
Unforgettable it is Anton shur played
expertly by Javier BM this was an actor
I'd never seen before this film but
within 5 minutes he was burned into my
brain what's the most you ever lost on a
coas but M cuts a cold and ruthless
figure in the film and we begin with him
being arrested over the top of this we
hear Sheriff Bell who's played by none
of than Tommy Lee Jones Bell very much
represents the old ways and how much the
world has changed around him Bell often
talks about how things were done in the
past with a future providing some scary
unknowns throughout her countown in the
olden days sheriffs never even carry
guns some of the old time Sheriff's
never read more gun this is something he
somewhat does too as when we see him
investigating Lin there is a little bit
about how he doesn't have his you going
in going out and
up
what my CH I'm behind you B represents
the idea of a past bill with ethics
who's Unsure how to operate in this new
world on the opposite side of this is
Anton Shar who represents chaos violence
and death we'll talk about it more as we
get into the video but this pair are
very much opposites of the same Co this
is H at home in the scene in the trailer
which takes place at different points in
the film Shar sees himself reflected in
the TV which is also something that bers
too the pair both sit and drink the milk
and together they sat in the exact same
spot however Belle's reflection is
refracted which symbolically carries a
lot of meaning this shows that he
doesn't quite recognize the world he's
now looking at and this movie is very
much about his failure in the end he
decides to retire which is because
there's No Country for Old Men He said
it he said it now but the book itself is
very much B's story in which each
chapter begins with his narration
throughout it we also learn of his past
which are thing helps to flesh out his
character in it we discover he served
during the second world war and one
night had a transformative moment Bell's
unit was attacked by Germans and in the
end he fled to save himself throughout
he clearly wrestles with guilt and
struggles to deal with the men that died
while he ran away to make up for this he
then became a sheriff which would act as
a way that he could help and protect
people in the end though B ends up
retired because he comes to grips with
the fact that Shar has got away Bell
sees himself as being unfit for the job
and unable to make a difference in these
Changing Times he says I always like to
hear about the oldtimers can't help but
wonder how they operated these times
showing how he views himself as being
someone who would have done better then
he wonders how they would have handled
these days but I think this speaks to
his own character B himself is really an
Oldtimer who's wondering that because he
finds himself stuck here he's wondering
how those people would have handled it
so it can inform what he should do next
it's masterful dialogue that let let you
know his predicament and how he feels
like he's stuck out of time now from
this point he rattles off a story about
a man who assaulted and killed a
14-year-old girl B at one point tried to
understand why he did it but he just
says I don't know what to make of that
it shows that he's out of his depth and
unable to comprehend the psychopathy
rampant in the world the buck touches
upon this too with a character saying
it's not about what he'd have to do it's
about what he'd have to become in order
to be Shar he'd have to become him and
it's not something that is willing to do
it's not that I'm afraid of it I always
knew you had to be willing to die to
even do this
job but I don't want to push my chips
forward and go out and meet something I
don't understand again it's about how
the older generation can't handle away
the world changes with the new and how
they may often be sickened by what they
see the title itself comes from a poem
called sailing to Byzantium which was
created by WB Yates the poems about a
man sailing to try and find a way to
stop being old but in the end you know
it's not something he can do either way
it's with this line that we meet Shar
who's then shoved into the back of a
police car a huge shout outs to logos
made flesh who did a brilliant breakdown
discussing the character it said
something that truly changed my
perspective and that is the design of
shigar himself the YouTuber theorized
Shar is the personification of death
with a character taking somewhat
inspiration for his depiction from the
seventh seal shar's hair could create
what almost resembles the her and this
ill-fitting cut makes his Facey more
Square beyond that though the seventh
seal has notable characteristics of the
Grim Reaper witchar also follows himself
the reaper carries a side which is a
tool used on farms rig girl's cattle gun
is well used on Farm life like cattle
yeah no [__] Sher beyond that though the
seventh seal is death playing chess with
the night faces off against gambling his
life in the film we see suar torning
people with a coin flip in which the
outcome will determine their fate huge
shout out to them them again for seeing
these similarities and to meigar sees
himself as a vessel of Fate he seemingly
does things at a random acts of violence
however when you think about it to him
they're not random he very much blames
his victims for making choices in life
that in the end put him on the path to
him he sees himself as someone who
delivers fate to those that were unlucky
enough to come face to face with him let
me ask you something if the rule you
followed rer of
this of what use was the rule to me this
is exemplified in two moments in which
Anton's near victims escape with their
lives the first of these is of course
the shopkeeper in what's one of the most
unforgettable movie scenes of all time
andon flips the coin to see this guy's
fade and the coin basically tells him as
fate as he should live coin flips is
something that I often used to make
decisions and I have to admit I've done
that a lot too whenever there's
something I just can't decide on I tend
to flip a coin to try and help with a
decision I'll be honest sometimes I'll
do my best out of three but having that
doubt about the first outcome also helps
me to decide now what's important about
the coin toss with the shopkeeper is
that there's actually three factors here
at play the first is fate which comes in
the form of shagar who arrives at this
moment bringing potential death the
second is Free Will in which the man
makes a choice in which he chooses
between heads or tails the third the
third is just luck but it's as important
as the other two to me these are the
three factors that make up almost every
decision and now with them being the
three pillars of life we will talk about
how luck appears throughout the film too
but the next victim I want to focus on
is the bird on the
bridge during this we see suar shoot at
a but he misses and we watch as it flies
into the night neither of these were
things that Shar had to kill and on the
surface they seem like random acts of
violence however he felt like this was
something he had to do because again
fate put them on the p hat to him it's
been traveling 22 years to get here and
now it's here he sees the bird flying
away is being fade and it also hints at
something else within him you see shigar
he's not the perfect killer and though
he has this belief he's subject to fate
too driving away at the end he randomly
gets hit with a car which could be seen
as Fay coming after him too it shows
that he's victim to the random chaos
that life is and isn't the Invincible
instrument that he'd have you believe
Anton's idea of Fate has become a cod to
which he believes justifies his actions
this has given him power over life and
death because he thinks he's acting for
a higher power as colagene says though
the coin don't have no
say it's just you which when you get
down to it's the truth behind the matter
Shar is just a violent man in a violent
world trying to make sense of all the
chaos around him at least that's how I
see it and if you disagree comment up
below but fate is very much the driving
force in shar's actions the we website
litcharts.com have a brilliant analysis
of the bck and film and they talk about
all the factors of Fate seen in Shar
Shar knows that everyone's going to die
one day and that we are all eventually
doomed to this fate what will factor
into how long it takes though is luck
and free will but in the end off fate is
decided fate is also evil and cruel to
the characters with it often rewarding
those who act in their own best
interests the Welling could have easily
left the cartel dealer but his
Consciousness weighed on him and he
headed back to give him water this then
almost got him killed and had he not
done it then he would have been okay he
lives his life based around rules as
does Carson but Carson's rules fail him
and lead to his death bell is someone
who follows the rule of law and this is
what he sees as being how to live this
is what puts him as an opposite to Shar
and in the end that's why he survives we
also have the exemplification of greed
shown in several characters who want
more more lelling could have easily have
ditched the money but instead he ended
up losing it all there's also the group
that he B buys a jacket from who keep
demanding more money for the beer that
beer
too how
much Brian give him the beer last year
the kids on the bike and as Anton walks
away we can hear them fighting over the
cash you know part of that mine right
you still got your damn shirt a even
what it was for I think this is why shur
is kind of above them because he doesn't
really want the money for himself he
returns it rather than being greedy and
thus in the end doesn't pay a cost yay
it's 2024 and we're back with one of my
favorite sponsors ag1 ag1 is a daily
Health habit that's filled with vitamins
and minerals Whole Food sourced
ingredients and probiotics so since
having the twins I've been a bit under
the weather pretty much all the time cuz
they keep going to nursery and bringing
back lots of colds and viruses with them
that's where ag1 comes in and with just
one simple scoop you get 75 vitamins and
minerals that replenish your daily
nutrients and leave you feeling better
having twins I don't get as much sleep
as I'd like and I used to just Hammer
the coffees and hope it would push me
through however ag1 just have it in the
morning as part of my daily Health
routine and it gives me the energy to
get me through the day H1 gives a
comprehensive nutrition supplement that
provides nutrients for your body brain
and good health and you're welcome kit
you'll get an ag1 pouch your a fillable
canister AG vitamin D12 and K2 you'll
also get the G1 travel pack shake a
bottle and a scoop as well it's got a
lovely vanilla and pineapple flavor you
guys will love the taste and all you
have to do is put one scoop in give it a
shake have it in the morning and you're
completely good to go for the day I'm so
used to doing it it's become a daily
Health habit but I look forward to how
it makes me feel cuz it just starts off
the day on the right foot just go to the
link in the description click that and
you're going to get a year free supply
of vitamin D3 and K2 plus five ag1
travel packs withth your first purchase
string a1.com slhe spoilers head there
now links in the description again
you'll get a year Supply vitamin D3 and
K2 plus 5 ag1 travel packs with your
first purchase pow it's honestly changed
the way I feel every single day you guys
can get the benefit too so just go that
link in the description and huge thank
you to A1 for sponsoring today's video
peace now after we meet you girl we hear
the narration rattling off these names a
lot of folks find that hard to believe
Jim scarber never carried one that's the
younger Jim Gaston Barkins wouldn't wear
one up in kamansi County these are real
figures from the time with a pair being
sheriffs of the counties where the movie
takes place now though people have gone
back and forth over where the movie
takes place place like I said at the top
it is 1980 we get that confirmed at
multiple points in the movie as the date
on the coin is 1958 we discover that
it's travel for 22 years and in the end
the math is mathing June 5th 1980s on
the southern western Bal phone bill and
col Jean's mother's grave has a year on
it too thus we kind of get the tone for
the film and this was a time in which
serial killers were on the rise figures
like Ted Bundy he was garnering
headlines just two years before and it
seemed like there was an epic epidemic
of killers murder is something that we
see from the off and shigar kills two
people within the first 10 minutes
strangling an officer we see is the
boots scrape the floor leaving thick
black marks that demonstrate the
struggle Shar is almost expressionless
refusing to Blink and it paints him out
as an unfeeling weapon of Fate now
Business Insider carried out an
investigation in 2018 in which they had
a group of psychiatrists watching 400
films this was in order to deem
Psychopathic characters with Shar coming
out as being the most accurate he's
clearly remorseless and completely Adept
at killing which we see demonstrated in
how he moves Shar shifts and rotates
with the officer and this means the
officer can't get a foothold all it
leaves is marks in the floor a chilling
reminder of what's just
happened now in the back there you can
hear the sound of a train which I think
carries a lot of meaning to it trains
are of course stuck on a track and thus
the destination always is the same they
are resigned to their path and in the
end they go to what's predetermined when
discussing why trains were used so often
the creative team also said the
following in an interview with variety
we had to find a way to give shagar his
normal theme with sound instead of using
a music piece so we started
experimenting with that distant Thunder
Rumble and that led to the train Motif
those locomotive noises Shadow suar
throughout subliminally reinforcing his
heavy Unstoppable approach the idea was
Shear a force that comes and goes and
like the fat represents he's on the wind
at this point he takes the police car
and pulls over someone on the road this
is when he uses the bolt gun and
mercilessly kills the driver just to get
his car in the back this is done in an
almost religious manner with him putting
his thumb to his forehead like a priest
of Vicor Shar says that if you're
imitating someone it might as well be
God and he is someone who has control of
life and death now the reason that Shar
carries a cattle gun is because of how
he views Humanity like I said earlier
this was studied on litchart who I think
did the best explanation for it they
said typically the air powerered bulk
gun is utilized in slaughter houses to
quickly and effectively Slaughter cattle
the fact that suar uses the buol gun to
kill his victims speaks to his
conception of human beings as no
different than animals Shar does not
believe in the concept of a Sol of the
afterlife so in his mind humans are no
different than any other organism the
bulon was also developed as a tool that
limits the chances of mistake in the
slaughter of cattle in the old days
individuals would use sledgehammers to
slaughter cattle but this old method
left plenty of room for error because
shar's goal is to deliver death quickly
and effectively without any room for
error the bulun provides the most
effective means to carry out his mission
the bulun is also an immensely pragmatic
tool Shar uses to gain entrance into
homes businesses and motels so all
around it's the perfect killing machine
and this idea of cattle is exemplified
in the victim here he simply H it out
the car and let you go kill him without
any protest the guy doesn't ask wise on
uniform doesn't ask to see his badge
doesn't try and move away when he starts
acting weird he just lets him put it up
to his head and then calmly kill him
shows how complicit people will become
in the face of authority and how little
questions they ask because they think
someone's in charge now an opposite to
this is lellan a guy who just won't go
with the crowd this is exemplified in
his first scene in which we see him
hunting this puts him in a dominant
position in which he's a predator
picking off his prey like you yeah he's
able to kill quote unquote animals too
but his shot doesn't deal a final
killing Blow instead it allows his
Target to escape and it limps away
leaving a trail of blood this
foreshadows what happens later on when
Shar and lellan finally have a shootout
lell manages to shoot Shar and he limps
away leaving a trail of blood now it's
also important upon out how his
character all flips as he's a hunter
here but he then becomes the hunted this
happens once he notices another trail
that sees a dog limping off and and it's
at this point that fate comes into play
but fate look Free Will and so on but
either way he stumbles across a deal
gone wrong it's luck that caused him to
not deal a killing blow and it was then
fate that led him to this point the luck
of the blood trail then showed him the
sight and it was fate from this point
that caused him to get involved now
another thing that I love about this
film is that we often just see the
aftermath of the [__] out this is very
much the case with the cartel and it
also happens in the case of lellan
shigar stumbles across his body towards
the end which reflects well in here
coming across the cartel now one of the
trucks he finds one of them alive and
this is something that stays on his mind
though he takes the money and could
easily be gone he decides to go back and
help out the man it's very much a saying
no good deed goes unpunished but in the
end it does extend his life you see the
money itself it had a tracking device in
it so shigar would have simply shut up
to his trailer Lan's Free Will made him
choose to go and give the water and in
the end this changed his fate as luck
would have it he managed to escape
though fate eventually caught him in the
end and from this point he goes looking
for the last man standing who we see sat
under a tree lellan holds up his watch
and the time's 20 to 12ish which it
might sound like a bit of useless trivia
yeah but they shot the scene at this
time so the Shadows would appear like
how they do when the sun's at that point
under the tree lellan then gets the
briefcase which is an Easter egg for con
brother fans this is the same one that
appeared in Fargo which I might do that
on the channel one day too when he
discovers the tracking device see this
is inside $1 bills and this was so that
if it got tossed away the loss wouldn't
be too bad putting a tracking device in
it also shows how suspicious the
businessmen were and that they were
expecting things to go wrong this
paranoia might have been the thing that
made the deal go south as we do know
that Cel had brought the trucks either
way lell returns home and we catch the
characters on the TV discussing this my
place is
wrong love how they mention about hiding
a spot after he just place a gun and
money under the trailer now this is the
film Flight to tangia which in itself is
about characters looking for $3 million
the three character is looking for it
they travel across country and yet you
can sort of see how it's it's all
connected he's unable to sleep and he
then heads out but we get a strange line
at this point I don't come back you tell
mother I love
her your mother's dead will now on
Reddit death by chocolate theorized that
this Line's foreshadowing what's going
to happen to his wife he likely knows
that people will come looking for the
money and this could end up with her
being killed so he talking to his
mothers because they'll both be in the
afterlife which the user thought showed
how careless that he was the point could
also be backed up by the fact she girl
say he won't kill her if L well in hands
over the brief case but in the end he
just decides not to personally I think
it's just duud to his pdsd and the fact
he's clearly not thinking straight in
this moment we learned that he's seen
combat before and that he is in fact a
Vietnam veteran you in the service uh no
sir I'm a veteran now uh yes sir two
tours I do wonder if like the sheriff
he's got regrets from the war and
perhaps you also left someone out there
to die this could be him trying to make
good on that as the Gil clearly won't
allow him to sleep sad in his truck we
see him looking over a map which is lell
in trying to plan out an Escape Route
arriving there we can catch the man's
being executed because the glass behind
them's now fully blown out cut back to
the scene before and you'll notice that
it isn't smashed up there spotting a
truck on the hill you can see they slash
his tires and from this point he has to
escape on foot as he runs to the water
he gets shot on the shoulder which
overall was pretty lucky for broling now
according to andyb trivia broling got
the PA and then two days later was in a
Mot of by crash this bust up his
shoulder and he said he was worried this
had ruined his chances of working with
the Cohen who would I as that he said he
greatly admired however they explained
it wouldn't really matter because lellan
in shelder was part of the character
after making a long swim we then C to a
gas station and learn about the coin I
always find it funny how we see 21 on
the tail and the coin's been traveling
for 22 years just a little just a little
heavy spoilers two time but I think this
might show that the guy's number could
be up due to his choices he's had 21
years and now must play a game with
death to decide his fate this is because
the attendant noticed the car was from
Dallas and might potentially tip off the
police just the way she girl stands it's
so intimidating and he mocks Clerk's
life in choices while shoving peanuts in
his
mouth even though he eats them there's
just something off about it and I really
don't know what the guy would make of
this encounter Shar almost lets it slip
but he leaves things even more unnerving
by pretending that it was just a normal
coin which it is I'll take your word for
it mate and we know that he's played
this before with other people as we do
see him pulling a handful of coins out
from his pocket this happens at roughly
the 52-minute mark and pay close
attention to the one at the bottom this
is some little specks of blood on it
showing how deadly the game's been
before all he's doing though is carrying
out their well with him simply wandering
through life following jobs in fate as
he said he got there the same way the
coin did and the final shot of him
wandering off seems to Showcase that too
he's hobbling along to who knows where
But continuing to go where fate will
take him he's at the wind and back at
the trailer lellan tells colag to go to
her mothers which is something that
impacts her later on also I'm just going
to start calling him Moss yeah cuz I
have to type out thewell in every time
his name comes up in the script and it's
do me bloody heading so you better smash
smash the [__] Thumbs Up Button now
out in the desert we see the other side
of the deal investig getting it these
are the ones with the money who import
the drugs and then sell it in America
Shear then ends up killing these two men
which probably has you you're scratching
your head but simply part this is
because she girl wants to work alone
later on with the accountant he
questions why so many people are looking
for the money he gave the Mexicans a
receiver he felt that the more people
looking that's
foolish you pick the one right tool Shar
sees himself as being the right tool and
that everyone else will just slow him
down this is why he also kills Carson
because he thinks these are all just
going to get in his way he wants to be
the one that delivers fight to MOS and
having others that deeply offends him
this is why he kills the guy in the
office who is that is that Steven root
anyway it's he's clearly mad that he
wasn't trusted and Views a lack of
confidence as being offensive from you
we see Bell and Wendell investigating
the scene and at this point they
recognize M's truck coming across the
two suar just killed they also say they
look managerial showing that the company
itself had been using its own men these
boys appear to be managerial this
explains how and why they had the
transponder whereas a gun for hire
wasn't given one at all once suar took
it though the company probably gave one
to the Mexicans and this was to have way
more people on the job anyway after sheo
investigates a trailer he goes to the
woman who works at the site we can't
give out no information you might be
wondering why he spares her when he's
had no trouble killing and threatening
others the first reason I think here is
because he hears a toilet
flush and this obviously lets him know
that someone else is there and there's
clearly a chance they could escape and
then call the police second reason
though is that this woman lives by the
rules and no matter what refuses to
break them I can't see someone like Shar
respecting this and it's factoring into
why he doesn't kill her thirdly just a
look at the toilet flush happening there
he might take that as being a sign from
fate either way she's spared and we see
as Moss drops his wife off on the bus
before heading to Del Rio giving the
option of Rights we sees he splashes out
getting a double room even though he's
just by himself you pick the option goes
with the applicable rate I'm just one
person so it don't matter the size of
the bed this could be in interpreted as
him trying to throw people off the S as
he's clearly aware that he's being
followed this is shown by him hiding the
case and then drawing the curtains
closed even though he's going out later
on when he returns to the motel he can
spot that someone's been in his room
this is because the curtains have been
open and thus he tells the driver to
take him somewhere else I I don't want
to get into some kind of a jackpot here
buddy it's all right take me to another
motel let's just call it Square as I
pull in you can see a truck parked up as
well which becomes something that
reappears throughout the film this
belongs to the other people chasing him
and it's who eventually get moss in the
end as bells pulling into the motel we
can see it speeding away with the
members jumping back in it realizing
that his paranoia is right he then buys
a shotgun intent which he says has to
have the most poles well you give me the
model number on the tent I can order you
the poles no never mind I want a tent
what kind of tent can with most poles
this is so that he can fish out the
briefcase using the poles to reach into
the vents he also buys another room so
he can stay close to the money and
pulling out a map of them he insists on
getting 38 well you can have the one
right next to yours if you want number
137 hit Ain took no 38 will be fine this
is because it's the one directly to the
back of his and it means he can listen
if anyone comes looking for him obvious
stuff but I just thought if we're
explaining it then we might as well not
leave any stone and turn now Shar ends
up getting a room and you might wonder
what it is that he's doing after all he
opens the door closes it then opens it
again quickly before he walks about
inspecting the room well this is because
he's planning his Ambush and trying to
figure out where everyone will be he
checks the thickness of the walls to see
if his weapon will fire through it and
also does something that's very
important this involves him taking off
his shoes and this is because he doesn't
want blood on them this is something we
sort of see playing out with Carson as
well as after killing him we see the
Blood Spells towards him and he then
decides to move his shoes out the way
now why I'm telling you this is because
it spells out in the end that yes sugar
does kill collagene though we never see
him giving the killing blow there's a
little clue as he steps out the house we
see suar checking his boots and this is
to see if they have blood on them had
collagene survive the coin toss then
there'd be absolutely no need for him to
do this in the book we get it confirmed
that he killed her so that's another
piece of evidence that helps to confirm
it now movie movies based on books yeah
they can of course do different things
but there's something in the sound
design that I think confirms it as she
go steps out we hear the sounds of bikes
which comes from the two boys riding in
the
street that sound it also appears at
another crucial Point namely when
colagene buries her
mother so in the end I think these
moments all come together and show how
we know collagene died a suar ends up
walking to the other room and his shoes
being off helps him to stay silent
however we again see that he's not
perfect as he incorrectly predicts where
one of the men are shooting at the
cupboard there's no one there and it's
something that could have cost him his
life from here the guy then steps out
and almost gets a shot at him luckily
he's able to react quickly and kills him
before taking out that final member
drawing the curtain close this is also
to stop him getting bloodied and it's at
this point that he takes off his socks
this point he also pulls out the coin
which he uses to open up the vents this
is summing Bell later finds on the floor
next to an open one submitting that Shar
had been there too now from here we C to
Carson who's played by my man you know
my man woody harlson the legend he's
been hired because they've crossed paths
before and unlike most people he managed
to survive now according to nbb trivia
in the book at this point they mentioned
some dope dealers that shot and killed a
federal judge that could actually have
ties with harlson as his dad shot and
killed a judge in 1979 both of these
incidents happened in San Anton anonio
with his dad possibly being what the
reference was if you've never heard of
him before genuinely it's mental and a
DI too down the Woody harelson dad
rabbit hole man was even implicated in
JFK's death and yeah definitely go check
that out right after this anyway when
describing Shari says yeah he's a
psychopathic killer but so what plenty
of them around this could be him scene
as being more dangerous than Shar as to
him psychopaths are a dime dozen I
believe that the scene also deals in Lu
as before Wells leaves he points out the
missing floor counted the floors this
building from the
street and there's one missing we'll
look into it this in itself could have a
number of reasons and the most likely of
these is that it involves luck
Superstition often had Builders not
labeling the 13th floor because many
believed that the number wasn't lucky
here Wells could be pointing out the bad
luck and as both these characters here
die that could be why this idea of
missing out the
is also seen later on at the motels when
Bell returns at night looking for suar
we can see that there's two doors with a
tape outside of them this jumps from 114
to 112 completely missing out the number
13 I do want to talk about that later on
but I think that's what Carson means in
this moment however in the buckets
reveal that it's a 17th Floor which
isn't listed for for security purposes
will say turns out this is where the
illegal operations are run from and
that's kind of why it's brushed to the
side still Lo helps to pain Wells that
is being observing and the IRS they
clearly haven't spotted this anyway
Wells goes to a hotel and we see him
checking in to 213 I think yeah and I
think you know what I think already mate
you watched these videos enough and this
is the room where it all starts to fall
apart he ask the man on the checkin to
give him a heads up and this is if
someone comes in looking for him later
on we learned that sh girl killed him
and there's actually a moment before
this in which you can faintly hear the
shot here's how it is in the film
however with a little bit of editing
magic we can boost that so you can hear
it better listen
[Music]
closely sorry about that listen listen
again this is of course would also
alerts moss and it comes off the back of
him discovering the transponder and
that's because we catch him lying in bed
once more unable to sleep this Echoes
the moment from earlier with the water
which again shows how a choice changed
his fate stand up against the wall we
see a picture with two people riding
horseback which many have interpreted as
being Bell stream can't remember who
said it so sorry for missing the shout
out but whoever it was they said that
Bell at the end talks about a dream in
which he and his dad rote out together
not sure if that's true I don't know who
said it so yeah let's say that's your
Easter egg mate that's the one you found
you should be bloody ashamed of yourself
anyway we see his Moss watches the door
and catar Shadow coming out from under
it it's such a chilling moment when you
just see see the two feet standing there
and you really don't know what way it's
going to go here we can hear the
transponder beep and it's Moss clicking
the gun that makes Shar realize he
wedding at this point he then goes and
turns out the light and shoots off the
lock which acts like a bullet and this
shootout is so intense cuz the pair
never really come face to face in it
they just taking pot shots at each other
and getting hit with Strays as they run
through the night one thing you might
notice as well is that when Moss
discovers a dead receptionist his cat's
still alive that's weird because here's
a guy who will happily shoot at a bird
but yeah he's left the cat alive now why
this was was theorized by wise crack who
said that it highlights his random acts
of violence there's absolutely no Rhyme
or Reason to what he does and seemingly
he just embodies chaos they talked about
how killing and harming animals is also
known as the kick the dog Trope which is
something that lets you know who the bad
guy is another Hallmark of the western
villain often calls a kick the dog
moment famous examples of this include
the
Searchers and Hondo all of which feature
bad guys killing or abusing a dog
letting us know that they are the worst
this Trope is also spoofed in Blazing
Saddles and the other things I pull from
a classic Western are the classic
archetypes we see in the characters
older Western used to feature good and
bad and this appeared literally as
something black and white the heroes
wore white hats the villains W black
which we see in both Bell and Shar a
building off the back of this wise crack
then brought up what happened during the
transitional 60s this saw the
revisionist Weston which started to
construct the confines of the genre he
added in characters that operated more
in Shades of Gray which they stated was
in line with moss moss of course shoots
a dog earlier in the movie which
normally is something that audiences
would hate however the good L man
character in the movie even point out
how bad it is to kill the dog they even
shot the dog this dog's the same breed
as the one M shot which shows he's
operating in those Shades of Gray Bella
is someone who's righteous and
upstanding and operates with full
morality she goes someone evil who
doesn't have any and Moss sort of exists
right between the two he will do things
that I deem bad but also do things I go
and give the guy water so just leaving
this cat alive has a lot going on with
it and it is something you can really
dive into at this point Moss makes it to
a truck and almost gets the guy to drive
him out the area however Shar ends up
shooting the driver and this makes it so
he can't escape in that sure Shar could
have aimed for M but him hitting the
driver means to driver seats filled and
he's got no way out still though Moss
makes an attempt and we see as he Hazard
steers the truck down the middle of the
road getting out he manages to finally
hit Shar but unfortunately his prey then
eludes him but this idea of being hunted
and a hunter can be seen in shar's name
which was created for the film the name
seaga in Spanish means to follow and
shika also means Hunter both of these
fit the character perfectly and all in
all M never fully gets the best of them
now this Pony heads across the border
and comes across some people that he
buys a jacket and beer off little
surprise for one of our followers Brett
harell he wanted me to point out this is
a templeton's Eagles jacket no idea what
that is but he said it's a little local
reference and he'd appreciate the shout
out so mate you're getting the shout out
I'm nice like that the band that wake
him up somewhat could be seen as mocking
him and rough translation of the music
spells that its meaning it's basically
about how someone wanted riches and to
touch the sky but in the end they were
just playing with fire back in the town
we then Curtis Shar who sitting outside
the Mike sauce Pharmacy this is a odd to
Mike sauce drugs which is where the con
Brothers apparently used to hang out the
location clearly meant a lot of them as
their production companies also called
Mike sauce Productions Shear ends up
robbing some supplies and in aot tally
stitches himself up on the opposite side
of this Moss ends up going to the
hospital which is where he's visited by
Carson in the book they explain that he
tracked his bloody Footprints and this
is how he traced him out to the hospital
Carson's approach is going as a friend
and he attempts to convince Moss to work
together with him we learned that Wells
was in Vietnam too and because of this
he sees them as allies Wells also warns
Sim that sh could go to adessa and kill
collagene which clearly ticks him off
Wells is overly confident and comes with
a kind touch because he wants to know
where the money is and knows that if he
kills him they'll never find out his
confidence is what leads to his death as
he believes he can outdo Shar in it we
see Bell sat with colagene and he then
tells the story about a man who tried to
put down a cow he says the guy one day
tried to shoot one in the head but it
was thrashing around so much that it
caused the bullet to Ricochet Charlie
grabs his gun there shoot the damn thing
in the head but with all the swinging in
the thrashing it's a glance shot
ricochets around comes back hits Charlie
in the shoulder you go see Charlie he
still can't pick up his right hand for
his hat obvious Illusions here had a
luck and chance but the count cattle gun
carry connections too shagura is the one
trying to put down Moss but his
thrashing around is causing more damage
in the end we don't know how injured he
gets and this story could work as a
metaphor for how things play out now
another thing here shows that he's out
of his death because he basically
describes what Shar does earlier in the
film they talk about how shar's victims
were found which as we learn had no Exit
Wounds B clearly knows it's a killing
tool too but he never makes the
connection to sugar or even why there's
no Exit Wounds to him these weapons
wouldn't be used on a human and thus it
shows he truly doesn't understand this
new world Carson then unfortunately
returns to his hotel and we sees he's
enable to bargain with Shar he offers
him money tells him he doesn't have to
do it but in the end he can't avoid his
fate still though he continues to
struggle but nothing he does is going to
change the outcome the phone then rings
and Sho realizes fate is intervene and
now made it so he's not needed at all
now back with bell we hear a story about
a couple out red out rooms at a motel
who then murdered them and cashed their
social security this was discovered
because a man ran in the street and we
learn that he was wearing a dog collar
it was a chance escape and it sums up
what's now happening with the world
which again B can't understand he starts
to question if he's fit to protect and
if we look back at Western conventions
it starts to become clear what his
character is wise crack pointed out that
he's basically your old western
character who's now been dropped into a
revisionist one the old ones were Simply
Good and Evil whereas a letter possessed
those Shades of Gray This is basically
The Good the Bad and the Ugly with each
character fitting into those archetypes
at the border checkpoint we then see his
Bells given preferential treatment
because he's a veteran though the guard
questions why he's in a hospital gown he
drops it once he hears of his past it's
possible that this is why Wells did the
same thing too as we learn at the end he
was a military Colonel returning to the
cloth shop we see another returning
character familier in the movie which is
when he first bought the clothes to me
this kind of shows MERS getting sloppy
because he's making it easier for him to
be tracked calling from the airport this
eventually leads to his downfall as he
gets collagene and her mother to travel
out to meet him while this is going on
shigar kills the man who hired him and
ends up sparing the accountant which is
when he says this are you going to shoot
me that depends do you see me with him
later telling the two boys that they
didn't see him had they said something
differently he probably would have
killed them and again it all operates in
the Realms of chaos take
it you didn't me I was already gone and
with colene and her mother we see us
there being tailed and get a quick shot
of the cartel in the car behind them
this is later the man who helps with her
bags and she unwittingly tells him where
it is they're heading to colagene then
tips off Bell which she does under the
pretense of him taking him in safely
while this is going on we see she go
hitchhiking and we get this little line
can you get those chicken grates out of
the
bed what are you talking
about
not a detail yeah but I just I don't
know it's got a dark sense of humor to
it with a quick cut of him cleaning out
the feathers now from here we cut across
the M who get offer to go for a beer by
a woman I got beers in my room oh I'm uh
waiting on my wife just out here you can
stay married oh man I I I know what beer
leads
to beer leads to more bear now we end
the scene with moss weighing at weather
to join her and whether he did or not is
sort of left ambiguous about I have my
own
time time about what happened I'll tell
you now now when Belle arrives we see
her dead in the pool and because of this
I don't think that MOS did again we're
going back to that idea of morality and
how no good deed goes in punished that's
because you know had Moss gone with her
back to the room then he would have been
cheating on his wife Captain Obvious
there but that would have been the bad
thing to do however in doing it he would
have been rewarded now I'm not talking
about being rewarded with more be but he
would have ended up alive the cartel
would have shown up but he'd be in her
room and thus out the way of where it is
they were looking Moss turning her down
led to him being killed and Bell arrives
to find him dead in his door it's a
tragic way to close out the character
but thematically that's the point of the
film you see sorry oh sorry forget I
forgot to end the time that's end you
get it right so basically what is
showing is the senseless nature of
violence and how real life is often
disappointing had this been your old
style of Weston then we could pretty
much line out how it would have gone
Moss would have ended up killing the bad
guys and Bell would have killed or
arrested Shar Moss would then ride off
with ker jeene with him getting to live
a life full of wonder instead we see ker
arriving at the motel to find a crime
scene and a husband dead there's no big
Showdown and nothing to be happy for and
all in all it's really depressing now
line that stuck out of me in this watch
shoe is how Belle feels about God I
always feel figured when I got
older God
would sort of come into my life somehow
you see B thought that God would come in
at the end and make him see that
everything had a meaning this is sort of
what the audience wants to with
something coming in in order to save the
characters movies often give us happy
endings but life itself it just isn't
like that even though we know the
characters are screwed we expect God to
come at the end and help everyone out
Bell will somehow catch you girl Moss
will get away and we watch as they ride
into the sunset instead M eyes Bell
retires and Sh girl manages to escape
the arm of the law it's all just
depressing and something that shows how
cruel the world is now later on B
returns to an old pal who we learn got
shot in the line of duty asked if he'd
kill the guy if he ever got released he
simply says what would be the point this
is quite a sobering line as it shows how
acceptance is something that's important
he then gives the truth of the matter
and really explains the way the world is
what you got ain't nothing new this
country is hard on people you see B
thinks that the world's getting worse
when in reality it's always been [__]
this in itself is a universal fact and
some have argued about with countless
people every generation they've got that
Elder figure that complains about the
good old days and this goes back
thousands and thousands of years I bet
if you got a time machine and went back
to ancient Rome you'd catch someone
saying things aren't the way they used
to be the point is the world's always
has been terrible but as you get older
you start to become wise to it remember
this movie set in the 80s which nowadays
is a time that people look back to funly
you go on Twitter right now and you'll
see thousands arguing about how bad it
is but the truth is we've probably never
had it better the world unfortunately
it's just a cruel place and those good
old days never really existed I was
speaking to my grand the other day and
she was someone who lived through World
War II hearing her stories I think about
how lucky I am and how people now we've
got it so good still though you get
people wanting to go back to that time
because they look back on the past with
rose tinted glasses the world sucks and
yeah congratulations it's always going
to suck now a huge shout out to wendon
who's done a brilliant breakdown on the
ending and they pointed out a line that
really stuck out to them that's vanity
the vanity here is because Belle
believes it up to him to save the world
which isn't really the case when Deon
spoke about his Messi complex and how he
thinks it's up to him to bring Justice
in the end though that's not the case
and he has to retire because he can't do
it that's what I take to be what bell
learns and we'll talk about his dreams
later on still though this theme is
carried across when he meets with a
sheriff he talks about those better days
if You' have told me 20 years ago I'd
see children walk in the streets of our
Texas towns with green hair these are of
course just quain meaningless things
that don't really show the downfall of
society still though the older
generation will always say stuff like
back in my day and to me Belle finally
becomes aware of it and back in my day
people used to subscribe to the channel
however he has to pass one final test
and we sees he drives out to the motel
this scenes had a number of
interpretations one of which I'll go
through before I do my own sunline one
of the major beliefs is that when we see
Shar stood behind the door this is
actually B's anxiety at play Shar did
travel there earlier in the film which
we get confirmed by the coin on the
floor this makes sense too as when Belle
stares at the Lock you can see what
looks like a figure moving in the
reflection however when the door opens
nobody's there the fact Bell saw what
could be his reflection and still
decided to open it though is a very
important thing it shows that he's ready
to confront his fear even though he
thinks shagar is behind the door now
ultimately this shows his strength
because he's willing to face the man
behind it earlier in the film he talked
about walking away from the table but
here we can see that he's going all in
honestly it's a good interpretation but
I like to think that should girl was
there now what I mean by that is that
there's two doors with both being
covered up by the police tape this
creates a 50/50 Choice much like well
its own little coin flip to me Shear's
hiding behind one of the doors and this
is why we C to him standing there this
is clearly happening at night and thus
to me it shows he was there alongside
him if we see the way the door opens
this bangs out to where sh girl would be
stood I highly doubt that he would stand
there knowing that the door could hit
him and instead he'd move to the other
side therefore the door must be on the
other side meaning that he's hiding out
in the other room if that's the case
then Belle survived because he ended up
choosing the right door obviously let me
know below and yeah I just love hearing
theories on this movie so you better
bloody be writing one anyway from here
we could to call a jeene who we can see
burying her mother going back home she
notices the windows open which was
obviously how sh girl got in a callene
really makes him confront his worldview
as she refuses to take part in his game
in the end it's him who's forced to make
the choice showing what he truly is
shigar is just a violent man who thinks
that he's acting for a higher power
really though he's just acting for
himself and in many ways the universe
betrays him coma comes in and kicks his
ass potentially showing it's now no
longer on his side because he still
carried out the kill without letting Kaa
choose he might now be out on his own K
jeene is the only person to speak to all
three characters and this may be why she
ends up taking him down either way he's
just like any other person who has to
take respons possibility for what it is
they do though she dies she may destroy
his worldview which in the end leads to
somewhat of his downfall that's what I
took from the way that he hobbles off
but again let me know exactly what you
think wait is that the is that the kid
from first class it's a it's the bloody
guy from get out get get out of here
anyway we end with Belle discussing his
dreams and in the monologue he said he
met his father who died before the ages
now so he seems like a younger man this
is something that always stuck out to me
and I think it's a line a lot of people
will experience the first Dream has the
pair just meeting in a town whereas the
second has them meeting up in older
times he says they rode up into the
mountains with them passing through snow
and darkness his dad rode past him
carrying a fire and Belle tried to
desperately get to him then I woke up
now the way I take it is that he's
trying to find comfort in this dark and
depressing place which he hopes will
come from his father he wants something
to guide him through which children
often expect from their parents however
he's never going to get that and he'll
always wake up from the dream this will
hit him with a cold harshness of the
world in which he realizes there's no
one to help kind of depressing but
that's how I took it about wendon had a
different interpretation that's because
of what they took from the book and what
its author Co M McCarthy tends to do in
his work see this movie was directed by
the Cohen Brothers but it was adapted
from a book written by Cormac McCarthy
cormack McCarthy is my favorite author
and he has this trick that he does
throughout his books where the themes or
Solutions of one film is is picked up
with as the meaning behind another what
I mean by that is things mentioned at
the end of one story and sort of WRA the
bow on the symbolism that has been
building up throughout is then used as a
narrative or the structure for the next
story he tells it's as if all of his
collections are symbolic sequels and
prequels of each other so following that
logic this movie is the predecessor to
the road the road which is my favorite
novel of all time follows the story of a
father and son going through a
postapocalypse the theme of struggle
against the world is brought up several
times through that story as well however
every time that the son asks his father
if what they're doing is worth it the
father tells the son that we are
carrying the fire what he means by this
is that in such a dark and desolate
World there needs to be those who carry
the torch now more than ever especially
in the story of the road it seems like
it'd be a great idea to just give up and
call it quits as the sheriff did in No
Country for Old Men but then who would
carry the torch this is what I mean by
the sheriff is the main character of
this movie not only is he the opening
and closing narrator but he's the one
that receives the character Arc
throughout this movie it wasn't L Ellen
it wasn't Anton it was the sheriff
learning that he alone can't save the
world and in these final moments even if
he doesn't recognize it yet he has given
the information of how to really save
the world I love that interpretation and
I I'd rather end the video on a more
positive note there's also a video by
what is anti logic who goes over why
they think Anton Moss are the same
person they pointed out that Shara is
similar to The Terminator that walks
around with a massive shotgun but no one
seems to notice him this is most notably
seen within the pharmacy explosion and
it also calls into question most of
Moss's motives things like why does he
keep the money in the bag and not move
it why does he leave the door open on
the drug dealer yeah go back for him
like he cares and there's a lots of
different things that could actually
hint this as true but then hypothesize
the entire movie could just be a story
being told to us by Sheriff Bell and
when you get down to it that makes a lot
of sense as well to what his anti logic
he thought the reason we don't see alos
died is because Belle never saw it and
when you think about it he didn't see
Shar either if the arise that his name
Ed Tom is similar to Anton and this is
why he chose him to be the evil of his
story if the Ariz that Anton just
represents this new kind of criminal
that in the end he can't put a name to
hell he doesn't even remember the story
about Charlie that he told the colagene
just a day earlier you know Charlie
Waller's got that place out Easter
Anderson Sheriff was that a true story
about Charlie waler who's Charlie waler
the theory then gets really crazy when
he States Anon and shigar are the same
person and they operate in a similar
manner throughout the story when we
first see Mary got his boots off with
the shoe obsession being something he
has throughout they both carry similar
shotguns and on top of this both buy
clothes from someone else he theorized
that the reason Anton went back to give
the guy war is because the Anton side
knew he had to be out there and ordered
to meet with the two guys the brother of
a scene in which they take off their
socks too and there's lots of
similarities that are shared between the
pair both could be different sides of
the same coin and it's definitely worth
checking out this video if this has
piqued your interest either way this is
a story that centers around three
characters who all have somewhat
similarities and differences to them in
the opening montage is the sheriff tells
a story we cut the three windmills that
we see throughout the Montage the first
of these is in the distance with it
representing Belle standing off away
from what's really going on the next is
moss which is represented in the next
one and the last one seems darker and
broken and th it's representing suar
details like this that show the
attention to detail and how much they
really put into the movie now definitely
go check out those other channels I've
mentioned as they've all got incredible
videos on the film that just make it
much more enjoyable watch I hope you've
enjoyed this one too and there's been
lots of work that went into it so please
hit the thumbs up button and that that
that'll be the last time I ask you if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button and as a
thank you'll get early access to videos
every week we drop these early for
members as well and with that you'll get
audio versions as soon as that's done
and then the edited versions before
anyone else so huge thank you to
everyone who's supporting us I've just
seen those numbers shoot up the last
couple of months and it really helps
videos like this get made we will be
back with Back to the Future 3 and then
going off to Summer Ale to break down
the Wicker man after Back to the Future
we'll be traveling with Terminator 3 and
yet lot to look forward to in 2024 have
you want some else St watch then make
sure you check out our right down of
Apocalypse Now which is almost as good
as as this video what do you mean this
one was terrible either way hopefully
see you over there huge thank you for
all your support again and without the
way I've been Paul you've been the best
I'll see you next time take care peace